President Trump goes full Trump Bernie
goes full bunny and the fresh faces go
fully fresh and fully faced I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show all
right well it's a busy weekend for
everyone and we are going to jump right
into the weekend's news there was plenty
of it but we begin today first by
reminding you that when you send
packages there's no need for you to
schlep on over to the post office post
office is great and everything but why
would you spend time in the car and
schlep your packages there and then
spend more money on postage instead use
stamps comets one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
stamps calm eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts you can't even get at the post
office stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service direct
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps comm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it's your mail carrier
or drop it in a mail box it is indeed
that simple with stamps comm you get
five cents off every first-class stamp
at up to 40% off Priority Mail not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters stamps
calm is a no-brainer it saves you time
and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm daily
wire is one of them I personally use
stamps calm at my house when it's time
to send mail I head on over to stamps
calm right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and the digital
scale with no long term commitments just
go to stamps com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that is stamps comm enter
Shapiro to try it out stamps comm mic at
the top of the homepage click on it type
in Shapiro for that four-week trial plus
free postage and the digital scale no
long-term commitments excellent service
and you get us discount when you use
promo code Shapiro so go check that out
right now alrighty so we begin with the
President of the United States over the
weekend so he spoke at CPAC over the
weekend CPAC is the Conservative
Political Action Conference I spoke
there last year it's a great event I
mean it's thousands of young people who
show up to hear from various members of
the conservative movement and they're
not so conservative movement it always
is an interesting mix because there's
every year controversy over sort of
who's the leadership of the conservative
movement well the last couple of years
the president has shown up and the Pres
is very comfortable at CPAC what I mean
by this is that the president will just
freewheel so he gave the longest speech
of his presidency at CPAC dude went for
two full hours two hours at CPAC and it
was the full Trump I mean it was that it
was every aspect of him the good the bad
the ugly the hilarious and the more you
see of him the more you realized that he
just sucks the oxygen out of the room
it's gonna be very difficult for any
Democrat to compete just with the amount
of attention that President Trump
gathers around him and my father made a
point one time about Barack Obama when
Obama was early on his presidents he
said one of the things about Obama that
he's truly great at is making himself
ubiquitous he's on every TV all the time
it feels like he's become a part of our
lives well Trump certainly has become
part of the American Life well does that
mean that it guarantees him re-election
of course not nothing guarantees you
re-election but he is so adept at
garnering attention to himself that it
makes it difficult to think of anyone
else in the race so maybe the idea is
that you're gonna vote for somebody else
as the default but let's remember
Americans tend to get pretty comfortable
with whomever is in office or at least
relatively comfortable with whomever is
in office right now his approval ratings
about the same as they were for george w
bush at this time before his reelection
or Bill Clinton before his reelection or
Ronald Reagan for that matter before his
re-election so this idea that he is
wildly out of tune with prior winners is
simply nonsense in fact the only
president who had really high reelect
numbers at this point was George HW Bush
who then went on to lose it's important
to recognize that the American people
generally don't like to change horses in
the middle of the stream they really
don't the last president who was a
one-term pret like a legit one-term
president who did not win a second term
specifically because of a third party
candidate you know didn't didn't lose
because in Ross Perot or something was
Jimmy Carter before I was born
so it's been 40 years since the American
people had a legit one-term president
like Jimmy Carter that's a long time the
American people to overcome that burden
the Democrats are gonna have to do
better and again President Trump is
adept at seizing the headlines because
he is a barrage I talk with friends in
the news business all the time and one
of the things we are constantly noting
about President Trump is that a day in
Trump time is like a year in regular
time
used to be that when Barack Obama was
president a day was basically half a
news cycle now one hour is half a news
cycle the half-life of trumpism is
extraordinarily short every two hours
there's a new news cycle from the
president because he's tweeting
something or something is going on or
the media are so rabid that they
generated controversy or people reacting
to him decide to create a story do you
remember when Brett Kavanaugh was
nominated you remember that that was
fully that was like three and a half
four months ago okay that's crazy that's
insane
remember that covington High School
controversy that was only about five
weeks ago six weeks ago that's how fast
time moves in the Trump administration
rather the news cycle is in the Trump
administration that means the Democrats
are dealing with a flurry from Trump
every time he is in public well at this
at the CPAC speech Nikhil SP makes this
point at reason calm Trump demonstrated
once again that he is just an
overwhelming presence in American
politics with some of the good and some
of the bad and some of the ugly so here
is the President of the United States
defending his emergency declaration now
it is important to note while the
emergency declaration with regard to
immigration is not popular among
Americans it isn't by by and large he
has not lost approval ratings for it
he's actually gained in the approval
ratings here's the president talking
about the emergency declaration last
month I declared a national emergency
and a lot of people talk about precedent
precedent that if we do this the
Democrats will use national emergency
powers for something that we don't want
they're going to do that anyway folks
the best way to stop that is to make
sure that I win the election we're very
concerned about setting precedent I'm
very concerned with having murderers and
drug traffickers and drugs and drug
cartels pouring into our country that's
what I'm concerned about now there's a
deeply unconservative argument the
president Trump is making right there
this idea well I can violate the
Constitution I can violate the balance
of powers because eventually Democrats
will too and the best way to prevent
Democrats from doing it is to make sure
that Republicans keep being re-elected
in other words give the executive branch
all the power and I Donald Trump will
ensure that that power is used how you
like it well that's not how Khan's
to tional government is supposed to work
which is why there's a good shot that
today the Senate is going to vote down
president Trump's national emergency
declaration forcing him to issue the
first veto of his presidency with that
said one of the benefits that president
Trump has is that he gets to argue the
Democrats are wildly out-of-the-box
uncaring when it comes to the effects of
illegal immigration when it comes to
drug smuggling and sex trafficking and
crime being brought into the country via
the southern border Howard Democrats
gonna combat this are they really gonna
combat it with the checks and balances
Arden because their own crowd doesn't
care about checks and balances and
Barack Obama certainly didn't care about
checks and balances and then President
Trump he always mixes the good with the
bad then he says something about the
emergency declaration that I think is
deeply unconstitutional and wrongheaded
and bad and if Barack Obama said it I'd
be livid and then he says listen I'll
sign an executive order defending the
First Amendment on campuses so here's
the good very soon signing an executive
order requiring colleges and
universities to support free speech if
they want federal research if they want
our dollars and we give it to them by
the billions they've got to allow people
like Hayden and many other great young
people and old people to speak free
speech
and if they don't it will be very costly
that'll be signed very soon
okay well I'll wait to see what the
exact extent of the executive order is
obviously you want that's remain within
legal boundaries but the basic idea
which is that college campuses should
not be given federal funding if they're
not going to protect the First Amendment
that obviously is true this is the thing
with Trump 1/2 hour speech 1 million
headlines then the president does what
the president always says he went after
the media coverage of his inauguration
crowd size he went after the Russia
stuff the president is basically a two
hour comedy routine and I'm not sure the
Democrats can keep up with this frankly
at our big inauguration speech you take
a look at those crowds and I watched one
of the evening shows that are ridiculous
how horrible they are how mean how
horrible I saw pictures that there were
no people those pictures were taken
hours before if you say something like
Russia please if you can get us Hillary
Clinton's emails please please
and then that fake CNN and others say he
asked Russia to go get the email
horrible these people are sick and I'm
telling you they know the game they know
the game and they play a dirty dirtier
than anybody's ever played the game okay
so listen again President Trump is gonna
have a lot too to run against the fact
that the media are constantly supporting
his agenda by going over the rails
against him the fact that Democrats are
constantly supporting his agenda by
inadvertently going too far in the other
direction the fact that the Muller
investigation continues to drag on
without any tangible result from it
here's President Trump going after the
Muller investigation then ripping on his
own Attorney General and the guy is a
walking comedy show when it comes to
American politics policy I'm sorry to
say simply does not matter very much the
question is which person are you more
comfortable with at this point I'm not
sure that people haven't grown
comfortable to Trump seriously because
at the beginning was like oh my god what
is this right it's like oh god he's like
he's like your drunk uncle at the
parties knocking over the barbecue and
now the house is on fire and what the
hell is going on
but now it's like okay well the house is
on fire and we put it out and he's still
kind of stumbling around and drinking
but all right everything is okay and
barbecues kind of tasty guess we can
live with that its president going after
the molar investigation and its own
Attorney General Jeff Sessions for
everything with President Trump becomes
old news sooner or later everything is
baked into the cake I know the cake is
very large at this point there's a lot
of stuff in there I know there's rat
bones and there's an old shoes and stuff
but it's all baked it we are we all know
what's in the cake and when it comes to
American politics sometimes the devil
you know is worse than the devil is
better than the devil that you don't
which we'll see in just a second anyway
here's President Trump suggesting that
people are trying to tear him down with
BS which to a certain extent is that is
certainly true we had the greatest
election in all fairness I used to hear
Andrew Jackson this was now greater than
the election of Andrew Jackson people
say that no people said I'm not saying
it
all right this was the equivalent to a
grater now we have people that lost and
unfortunately you put the wrong people
in a couple of positions and they leave
people for a long time that shouldn't be
there and all of a sudden they're trying
to take you out with bull okay these
Democrats have a response to this
I mean seriously they can try to
schoolmarm President Trump and Hillary
Clinton try that in 2016 and schoolmarm
again didn't work you know why because
people are tired of it they're just
tired of the school murmuring you think
Kamala Harris school of arming President
Trump is really gonna do anything Joe
Biden schoolmarm impreza dn't Trump is
gonna do anything really the American
people they know they like all right
it's all there we get it in a second I'm
gonna get to a little bit more of
President Trump at CPAC and then we'll
get to why the Democrats best shot
they're there they could very well blow
it and get to that in just a second
first let's talk about hiring hiring
used to be hard multiple job sites
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process but today hiring can be easy you
only have to go to one place to get it
done that zip recruit calm slash daily
wire zip recruiter sends your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technologies zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
then invites them to apply to your job
as applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one they spot like the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match a zipper career is so effective
that 80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
and right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiters comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash
Dai ly WI re zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiters indeed the
smartest way to hire there's no reason
for you to be posting your job on 1
million separate job boards and then
waiting for the resumes to come in
without any sort of filter zip recruiter
makes sure that you spot all of the best
applicants they're so effective again
80% of employers who post on zip recruit
to get that quality candidate through
the site in just the first day zip
recruiter comm slash daily wear to try
zip recruiter for free ok so President
Trump again the fact is that people have
gotten used to President Trump and
normally normally I think that President
Trump would be unpalatable to the
American people this comedy routine
would get
quickly because well it is true that the
American people have gotten used to this
it is also true that if the Democrats
were saying in any way if they weren't
crazy bat bleep loonies if they didn't
if they didn't push so far to the left
that Bernie Sanders were now a
mainstream presidential candidate they'd
have a much better shot in this election
I'm not talking about school murmuring
I'm just talking about a return to
normalcy somebody standing there going
listen I know you think this is fun I
know this is all fun and games but like
come on guys come on but they're not
going to do that they're not gonna do
that even though President Trump
provides pathways to vulnerability for
them I mean the fact is he just does for
example President Trump last week I
ripped on him for this the president
said that otto warmbier the American
citizen who was murdered by the North
Korean regime
he said that otto warmbier head that he
took Kim jong-un and the evil dictator
at his word that he didn't know about
otto warmbier and then frump went on at
CPAC and he said listen the reason that
I said all that I'm in a horrible
position how can the president say this
publicly like how is this okay we got
our great people back we get our great
great people and that includes our
beautiful beautiful otto otto warmbier
whose parents have gotten to know who's
incredible and I'm in such a horrible
position because in one way I have to
negotiate in the other way I love mr.
and mrs. warm beer and I love Otto and
it's a very very delicate balance he was
a special young man and to see what
happened was so bad okay it's not
actually a delicate balance you do not
have to praise the dictator of an evil
country or the an evil government the
dictator of evil government to be more
precise the country isn't he all the
people I'm sure a great but the
government is terrible and evil the fact
is that he praised Kim Jong Lu and he
did not have to do that it was so bad
that even John Bolton had to come out
and condemn president Trump's view he
said listen that's Trump's view that's
not my view this is the secretary this
is the National Security Advisor John
Bolton the president made it very clear
he considers what happened to otto
warmbier an act of brutality that's
completely unacceptable to the American
side I've heard him before the summit
itself before the Prescott
friends talk about how deeply he cared
about otto warmbier and his family the
fact is the best thing North Korea could
do right now would be to give us a full
accounting of what happened and who was
responsible for it
do you take Kim jong-un at his word the
president takes him at his word but what
about you my opinion doesn't matter
and my opinion is that I can imagine
security of ours at the present right I
understand it matters quite a bit I am
NOT the national security decision-maker
that's his view okay well again this is
bad stuff now here's the point that is
bad stuff but Democrats are not
positioned to take advantage because the
2020 Democrats are so unbelievably
radical so unbelievably radical that
Bernie Sanders may not be radical enough
for them so Bernie Sanders is trying to
reintroduce himself to the Democratic
Party right now and yeah that means that
we have to play the Bernie Sanders music
of course because I mean come on so
Bernie Sanders gave a big speech over
the weekend and that speech was supposed
to reintroduce him to the Democratic
public right he's speaking in brooklyn
new york and the idea here was going to
be that he is going to reintroduce
himself as the new face of the
democratic party make himself more
personal to the democratic party the
problem is that Bernie Sanders is a kook
he has always been a kook and now Bernie
Sanders is trying to play up his Jewish
background in order to claim that he has
some sort of intersectional appeal
number one that ain't gonna play with
the Democratic Party the Democratic
Party does not care about Jewish
intersectionality they do not care about
the experience of Jews they do not care
about anti-semitism within their own
party as we'll get to in just a second
second of all Bernie Sanders does not
have a credible leg to stand on when he
talks about his Jewish background the
guy's radically anti religious he's
radically anti-israel he has no
relationship with Judaism he's an
atheist socialist like the fact that he
is ethnically Jewish make cuts no ice
with me I don't care about ethnic
Judaism I care about actual practicing
Judaism I care about religious Judaism I
care about Jewish principles Bernie
Sanders is in line with virtually none
of them and yet when he tries to
reintroduce himself to the Democratic
Party that's what he has to rely on
because his socialism isn't enough these
days so he drags out Shaun King Shaun
King you'll recall is the easy columnist
for the New York Daily News race baiter
par excellence there have been
accusations that he's not actually black
his birth certificate lists his birth
father as a white guy he says that his
mom had an affair and he's actually
black
not of high relevance but he is now a
spokesperson for the Bernie Sanders
campaign basically and he gets up there
in the middle of a Democratic Party
meltdown over anti-semitism and says you
know Bernie Sanders grew up in the
family of challah caught ones extended
family was killed in the Holocaust yeah
welcome to being a Jew okay pretty much
everybody's extended family was killed
in the Holocaust half of world Jewry was
exterminated during the Holocaust
doesn't give you a case for being
president here in Brooklyn the same year
the Holocaust began the next year when
Bernie was just a baby boy his uncle's
Jacob and Abraham his aunt Shawna and
her son Leopold were all killed in the
Holocaust in Poland and to come of age
in that time in that space it gave
Bernie a deep sense of right and wrong
okay so let me get this straight
because he was born the same year that
the Holocaust began he has a deep sense
of right and wrong this is their case
this is gonna be the case that Bernie
Sanders a full-on socialist who rooted
for the USSR and Cuba and was rooting
for Venezuela that guy is he got a deep
sense of right and wrong because he had
extended relatives who were killed in
the Holocaust just like every other Jew
on planet Earth of Ashkenazi descent
seriously and then Bernie tried to
double down on this he says you know I
know where I came from
he said he tries to describe his his
childhood and make himself a man of the
people even though he's been living off
the public dole for legitimately decades
at this point I am NOT going to tell you
that I grew up in a home of desperate
poverty that would not be true but what
I will tell you is that coming from a
lower middle class family I will never
forget about how money or really lack of
money was always a point of stress in
our family my experience as a child
living in a family that struggled
economically powerfully influenced my
life and my values I know where I came
from okay where you came from is the
greatest country in the history of the
world were a useless old man
you can run for president on the basis
of accomplishing nothing over the course
of your life and then you can rip on it
is that really gonna counter President
Trump is that a counter to President
Trump when President Trump stands up
there at CPAC and he says socialism is
not our future and then Bernie Sanders
says I grew up lower middle income in
the United States and this is supposed
to be a story of victimhood you're
standing on a presidential stage never
having legitimately earned a dollar or
created a job and we're supposed to hear
from you that you're the guy who should
run everything like that's the guy who
they're gonna juxtapose and let's not
forget him Bernie Sanders is a
front-runner right now he is his support
is significantly more durable than Joe
Biden's the best a Joe Biden's going to
have this campaign is the first day
unless Barack Obama endorses him the
best day Joe Biden has in this campaign
is the day he announces from there it is
all downhill Bernie Sanders has the most
durable base of anyone in the Democratic
Party and he is an octogenarian
socialist with a boring background so
boring that he has to actually go back
to extended relatives killed in the
Holocaust and growing up lower middle
income in Brooklyn just like half of
Jews in America like really and then he
says that his his program is going to be
guaranteeing health care as I said this
rally he's gonna guarantee health care
as a right but then he lets the the ball
he sort of lets the the cat out of the
bag as we'll see what he means by that
in an interview that happened last night
so here he is at the rally talking about
health care is right political
revolution and we say to the private
health insurance companies whether you
like it or not the United States is
going to joy in every other major
country on Earth and guarantee health
care to all people as a right yeah
except then he explained exactly what he
means by that he said oh yeah what I
mean by that is the complete elimination
of private health care insurance whoops
your question in terms of health care
we're already paying for it we're paying
twice as much as the Canadians so what
the criticism of Bernie Sanders is he's
gonna raise your taxes well I'm a that's
right but you know what I'm doing I'm
doing away with all of your private
health insurance premiums all right I
don't know how you guys work at where
you get
health care from somebody is paying for
it somebody's paying BlueCross the
UnitedHealth re that's gone paid for us
up yet you pay enough yourself humph you
payin if you're an average family of
four in this country pain $28,000 a year
and that course is gonna go up so we
can't afford the present system so we
didn't get rid of a hundred and seventy
seven million million health care plans
in the United States cuz Bernie Sanders
says so and his cases that he had
extended relatives who died in the
Holocaust and grew up lower middle
income in Brooklyn before sponging off
the taxpayer for decades at a time yeah
President Trump might be okay he might
be okay we'll explain why he might be
even more okay because Bernie Sanders
isn't even radical enough for the
Democratic base this is the problem
Bernie Sanders may be the best they have
to capture the Democratic mind at this
point but he is not the Democratic base
I'll explain in just a second first
let's talk about Congress in a second
we're going to talk about the fresh
faces in Congress and why these folks
cannot be trusted with power but here's
the problem as power accretes to the
federal government whether they're
talking about the legislature or the
executive branch as we talk about the
perversion of the constitutional
structure of checks and balances
regardless of who is in office we're
gonna need to shore up the Constitution
that has been undermined over the last
century the rise of administrative
government has radically restructured
how American government has worked and
was supposed to work it was never
supposed to be this way we weren't
supposed to have armies of regulators
trying to take control of every aspect
of your life we weren't supposed to have
a legislature that was constantly
accreting power to itself in a Supreme
Court that was constantly saying that
was totally fine this is why I'm a big
believer in calling a convention of
states where we the people can propose
amendments amendments that could force
term limits on Congress for example or
make them balance the budget we'd
consider all of these amendments and I
know people are worried about a runaway
convention here's the thing a vast
majority of states like 38 states still
have to actually go with whatever
amendment is proposed it's not like
somebody's gonna make an amendment to
abolish private profit in the United
States and that's gonna go find that's
just not how this thing works calling a
convention of states may be the only way
to get the job done they're already 3.8
million people with us on this more
every day join me and my friend mark
McClure go to convention of states calm
/ban go sign the petition today that is
convention of states calm slash Ben and
getting familiar with the Constitution
and then seeing what we can do to
restrike the original bargain would be a
worthwhile thing convention of states
calm slash Ben to join us go check it
out right now okay so as I say Bernie's
is extraordinarily radical and he's not
even radical enough for the Democratic
base this is why unfortunately I feel
like constitutional concerns have gone
by the wayside and we let off with
President Trump talking about his
emergency declaration and he says listen
you know I know that I may be violating
the Constitution here but if you're
worried that I'm setting a precedent
well Democrats are gonna do it anyway
because they have no limits when you
look at the Democratic Party it's hard
not to feel the same sort of flight 93
urgency that was expressed by Michael
Anton in this famous piece for the
Claremont Review of Books back in 2016
he suggested basically the country is
gonna crash anyway you got to vote for
Trump because you got to try to storm
the cockpit the metaphor didn't make a
whole hell of a lot of sense but if you
look at the Democratic Party right now
it does feel like this is a party that
is determined to drive America into the
ground this is a party that does not
care about Constitution or limits or
even frankly the limits of decency
Bernie Sanders is not intersectional
enough for them he's too socialist and
not intersectional enough so for example
CNN's Bakari sellers he came out on CNN
last night he said listen I know Bernie
marched with Martin Luther King right
this is one of the good part of Bernie's
records but he says that's not enough
Bernie isn't intersectional enough he
was criticized last time for not
connecting effectively with the
african-american community is this part
of what he needs to do to get the
nomination I know you're not necessarily
rooted on what I think I think that
Bernie Sanders has a long way to go and
there's a certain part of me that
believes that ship has already sailed I
mean it's not the fact that Bernie
Sanders marched with dr. King in the 60s
I think that was one of the first things
that he said the question was where have
you been and what have you done since
then what where has been where as your
activism been since the sixties okay
well here's the problem for this Pocari
Sellars does speak the language of the
base meaning he is talking to the
Democratic base but the Democratic base
is not the entire voting population of
the United States nor is it even the
voting population of the Democratic
Party there's a poll out of South
Carolina today here's what it shows it
shows that Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
are the only two candidates to reach
double digits in the Democratic primary
Biden has 37 percent of the vote right
now in South Carolina
followed by Bernie with 21 percent of
the vote Kamala Harris comes in third
with 9 percent of the vote Cory Booker
has 6 percent
beta o'rourke Elizabeth Warren both
received 5 Elizabeth Warren is toast she
is done she is not a competitor in this
race
Kamala Harris
is charting really low among black
voters and that's what's so fascinating
about this among african-american
Democratic primary voters Biden has 43
percent of the vote
Sanders has 15 percent of the vote
Harris is at nine so for all the talk
about how intersectionality is going to
rule the future the reality is is a
minority even in the Democratic Party
probably but it is a minority that is
now running the party
the folks who cares so much about race
and sex and the intersection there of
those people run the heart of the
Democratic Party but the Democratic
Party is not relegated to just those
people on the issue of reparations for
african-americans 31 percent of
respondents among Democrats agree with
the policy 46 percent disagree that
issue is not helping Kamala Harris with
South Carolina Democratic primary voters
according to the poll 79 percent of them
support reparations but they are
breaking for Joe Biden nearly four to
one by the way President Trump has a
positive approval rating of 50 percent
in the state so in any case this is sort
of the point as the Democratic Party
moves ever further to the left president
Trump's chances get even better as I've
said for a long time if President Trump
can just let the Democrats go crazy and
continue to go crazy and not go crazy
himself he may be in good shape and good
good news for him the Democrats appear
to be going fully crazy they're now
eating their own so Ilhan Omar continues
to be a fresh face of the Democratic
Party incredibly fresh as well as face I
mean on the cover of Rolling Stone with
Nancy Pelosi who also is a fresh face
meaning that she's had a chemical peel
in the last 30 days in any case Ilhan
Omar will not stop with the
anti-semitism I mean legitimately will
not stop can't stop won't stop turn down
for what
and she it's it's incredible she has
made three openly anti-semitic public
statements in the last month and a half
and has apologized twice not for this
latest one and she's being celebrated by
the Democratic Party so fearful of
ticking off their intersectional base
how do you think that's gonna play with
the broader American public I don't
think it's gonna play all that well so
over the weekend Aloha Ilhan Omar - so
Nita Lowey tweeted out this Nita Lowey
is a Democratic Congress person from New
York and here is sort of what happened
first a couple of things
Ilhan Omar last week suggested once
again
that Jews were Jews in America and
American Israel supporters were
demonstrating dual loyalty loyal to to
Israel as well as loyalty to America and
that if the two came into conflict it
was really going to be loyalty to Israel
that one out hey then in West Virginia
some idiots at the West Virginia GOP
wanting Johann Omar to hold their beer
apparently they tweeted it out or they
put up a poster that had a picture of
9/11 and it said never forget you said
and then underneath it was a picture of
Ilhan omar saying you forgot as though
Ilhan omar is somehow a member of al
qaeda al hahn omar isn't is terrible in
a lot of ways she's not a member of al
Qaeda that's absurd it's absurd and
indeed it is quote unquote Islamophobic
it's Islamophobic in the sense that not
every Muslim is a sense is a member of
al Qaeda now that doesn't mean that
Oakland Omar is any great shakes she's
not she's joked about Al Qaeda before
she is she has essentially expressed
sympathy for other terrorist groups like
Hamas and Hezbollah but is she
responsible for now of course she is not
but when she is called on her own and
but but the amount of inside the
Democratic Party it turned into well you
know let's condense height this
Islamophobia by Johanna Mar against
Ojeda Mar is truly terrible but we're
just gonna ignore the whole anti-semitic
thing we're gonna ignore the fact that
she's an anti-semite I'll explain in
just a second first let's talk about
your sleep quality there's nobody on the
planet like you so why would you buy a
generic mattress built for everyone else
helix sleep built a quiz it takes two
minutes to complete they use the answers
to match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
whether you are a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or a
firm bed with helix there's no more
guessing in no more confusion just go to
helix sleep calm slash men take their
two minutes sleep quiz they will match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life for couples
helix can even split that mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
they've got a 10 year warranty you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
right now helix is offering up to a
hundred and twenty-five bucks off all
mattress orders get up to a hundred
twenty-five bucks off at helix sleep
comm slash Ben that's helix sleep calm
slash man from two one hundred and
twenty five dollars off your mattress
order helix sleep calm slash Ben go
check them out right now my wife and I
have a helix sleep mattress it is indeed
indubitably comfortable it is great my
wife and I took that two-minute sleep
quiz the mattress came in the mail we
just unwrapped it and flayed it right in
front of us we popped it on the bed it's
good to go we've been on it ever since
it is fantastic
go check them out right now
Helix sleep calm / been used the / been
for up to 125 bucks off your mattress or
to go check that out right now okay
we're gonna get to the continued
radicalism inside the Democratic Party
plus a OC running into a trap of her own
making well get to that in a second
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daily wire calm and subscribe for $9.99
a month you can get a subscription to
daily wire when you do you get the rest
of the show live you get two additional
hours of me every day every afternoon
we're here suffering through the
afternoon commute with you and you can
be part of it all you have to do is go
and subscribe it's a Lee Weyer comm for
$9.99 a month or $99 a year in which
case you get this the very greatest and
beverage vessels the leftist years
hot or cold tumbler go check that out
right now it is indeed fantastic also
when you subscribe you get all sorts of
other goodies you can be part of our
mailbag I answer questions sometimes
during the show during the during the
radio breaks you can go check that out
also our Sundays specials become
Saturday specials so for example we had
on den Crenshaw Dan credit the
representative from Texas his Sunday
special you could get it on Saturday and
here the extra question so all sorts of
good stuff happening over at Daily wire
calm this is why you should go and
subscribe and become part of the team
helps support the show it really is
helpful to us also check us out at
youtuber iTunes listen the leave a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so as I say the Democratic Party is
moving so far to the left at least the
leadership is or the perception that the
intersectional base is the coalition
that is going to win the future that
perception is so strong that it is
leading them directly over a cliff like
lemmings so as I as I mentioned Ilhan
Omar he's gotten all sorts of attention
because she's a Muslim Congress person
from Minnesota who also happens to be a
blatant anti-semite again she said
anti-semitic things repeatedly she's not
the only one Rasheeda Talib from minute
from Michigan has done the same thing
well last week she said in a public
statement I mean in front of a major
crowd at a bookstore in Washington DC
she went out there and she suggested
that American Jews have dual loyalty to
Israel Nita Lowey who is an American Jew
and a Democrat tweeted this edge said
gross Islamophobic stereotypes like
those about Ilhan omar recently featured
on posters in West Virginia are
offensive and have no place in political
discourse anti-semitic tropes that
accused Jews of dual loyalty are equally
painful and must also be roundly
condemned lawmakers must be able to
debate without prejudice or bigotry I am
saddened that representative Omar
continues to mischaracterize support for
Israel I urged her to retract the
statement and engage in further dialogue
with the Jewish community on why these
comments are so hurtful and this has
been the typical tactic from folks on
the left really the typical tactic is we
are so sad that she would do this it's
so sad and you get the same thing from
debbie Wasserman Schultz another Jewish
Congress person this one from Florida
should sadly misunderstandings over
anti-semitic hurtful comments continue
as does hateful Islamophobic rhetoric
dialog leads to understanding johann
omar repeated misunderstandings would
seem to require dialogue to avoid
repetitive harm communication is the key
to understanding I hope you will agree
and will engage the tensions do not
worsen again it's the entire Democratic
Party tut-tutting Johann Omar's
anti-semitism she is not hiding the ball
guys she's saying it straight out over
and over and over again and all you
folks in the Democratic Party in
leadership positions are sitting there
going well I guess she just doesn't
understand she just must not understand
what she's doing this is soft bigotry of
low expectations crap she's an
intelligent woman she's a sitting
congressman the idea that Ilhan Omar
doesn't know what she's saying is absurd
she knows precisely what she's saying
because she keeps saying it over and
over and then she doesn't apologize for
it she apologizes that you felt bad
because of what she said so she responds
to Nita Lowey a
kradic congresswoman inside her own
party and she says our democracy is
built on debate congresswoman I should
not be expected to have Allegiance or
pledged to support to a foreign country
in order to serve my country in Congress
or serve on committee the people of the
fifth elected me to serve their interest
I am sure we agree on that that is
legitimately her suggesting that
everyone who supports Israel has
allegiance or pledge of support to
Israel no one is expecting her to
pledged her allegiance to Israel no one
is expecting her to even support Israel
there plenty of Democrats who do not
Bernie Sanders is one of them
but the people who come out in the
Democratic Party and suggest that
everyone who supports Israel has
allegiance to Israel that is an absurd
absurd anti-semitic contention she
engages in it like every five minutes
and the entire Democratic Party
infrastructure just tut tut sit just go
oh well you know who cares no it's
hilarious about this is AOC as ever
Leroy Jenkins saying every issue so
everybody in the Democratic Party Hall I
guess she just misunderstood it's a
misunderstanding guys I mean come on you
can't expect a lejano Mar to you know
know things so AOC then tweets out and
tacitly admits that a tell hen Omar
engages in anti-semitism
she says I'm pretty heartbroken there
isn't more denunciation of this outward
and blatant expression of bigotry in
Islamophobia by a state party first of
all I've not seen up major Republican
who has not condemned that West Virginia
poster it's a poster she's a sitting
congresswoman Ilhan Omar the amount of
outrage should not be should not be
equal in any case AOC then continues
very fresh very face in my opinion those
who stood up against anti-semitism a few
weeks ago should also be calling out the
Islamophobia here - isn't she tacitly
admitting that Ilhan Omar engaged in
anti-semitism and yet she continues to
support every aspect of Ilhan Omar
everything about al Haram are is worthy
of her support and then people wonder
why so many people are polarized and
voting for president Trump and thinking
about voting for President Trump you
want to make the choice binary Democrats
are making it real easy to make the
choice binary here's what President
Trump wants out of this election he
wants the same thing that he got in the
last election he wants people to look at
the Democrats and say I cannot pull the
lever ever for those people at least I'm
used to President Trump at this point
I'll pull the lever for him at least he
isn't engaging in outright anti-semitic
defense at this point Democrats are
at least he is not pushing and stumping
for this destruction of all private
health care insurance at least he's not
advocating for open socialism and the
destruction of cars and planes at least
he's not doing those things Democrats
are making it real easy for President
Trump they really are and it's amazing
to watch them do it seriously I mean
again the fact that Bernie Sanders is
considered a mainstream presidential
candidate is more of a joke than Donald
Trump winning in 2016 it is from any
objective point of view the worst you
can say about Donald Trump is that he's
an ignoramus who doesn't understand
politics very well and doesn't have
deeply rooted principles at least he's
not at least he understands enough to
know socialism is bad at least he
understands enough to know that
nationalization of massive industries
and destruction of 177 million
healthcare plans would be a bad idea at
least he knows that my goodness
it really is astonishing okay so
meanwhile IOC has gotten herself in hot
water how she got herself in hot water
well according to the New York Post
apparently aoc is another one of these
do as I say not as I do
leftists when it comes to
environmentalism he's a freshman
representative Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
wants to save the planet with her green
new deal but she keeps tripping over her
own giant carbon footprint we're like
the world is gonna end in 12 years if we
don't address climate change the
progressive darling said in January
speaking of herself and her fellow
Millennials and like this is the war
this is our world war two last week she
ratchet up the rhetoric she said it is
basically a scientific consensus that
the lives of our children are going to
be very difficult due to climate change
and she asked whether it was still okay
to have children because again she is
not a smart human and then the New York
Post said the guiding principle of her
eco vision is to bring about a full
transition off fossil fuels and zero
greenhouse gases within ten years to
achieve this the G and the green New
Deal fact sheet says the nation this is
the fact sheet she put out the
frequently asked questions the nation
must totally overhaul transportation by
expanding by massively expanding
electric vehicle manufacturing building
charging stations everywhere building
out high-speed rail creating affordable
public transit available to all with the
goal to replace every combustion engine
vehicle but the women who boast of a
razor-sharp BS detector seems to have
trouble sniffing out her own since
declaring her candidacy in May 2017
Ocasio court says his campaign heavily
relied on those combustion engine cars
even though a subway station
was just a hundred and thirty-eight feet
from her Elmhurst campaign office she
listed 1049 transactions for uber lyft
juno and other car services federal
filings show by the way she also blamed
those car services for bankrupting taxi
drivers the campaign at 505 Ober
expenses alone in all Ocasio cortez
spent $30,000 on those emissions spewing
vehicles along with car and van rentals
even though her queen's headquarters was
a one minute walk to the 7 train the
campaign shelled out only about eight
thousand bucks on 52 metro card
transactions everyone topped about him
used Metro cards Ocasio cortezes
spokesperson corbin Trent told the Post
by comparison her fellow freshman max
Rose listed only 329 transactions for
car services totaling $6,000 in
districts with limited transit options
and a $17 Verrazano Bridge toll Rose
spent only 732 bucks more than AOC on
gas and tolls an indicator of personal
car usage so she's been very friendly to
embrace airplanes and cars as well it's
more of that in just a second so it
turns out according to the New York Post
that AO sees campaign embraced the
friendly skies
logging 66 airline transactions costing
twenty five thousand dollars during
campaign season the Democratic firebrand
or her staff took Amtrak far less only
eighteen times despite high-speed rail
being the cornerstone of her
save-the-world
strategy so this is this long piece
talks about her travel habits and she's
very very upset about this so she tweets
back I also fly and use AC living in the
world as it is isn't an argument against
working towards a better future the
green new deal is about putting a lot of
people to work in developing new
technologies building new infrastructure
and getting us to 100% renewable energy
well also your frequently asked
questions specifically talk about
getting rid of internal combustion
engines and getting rid of airplanes I
mean I mentioned this when she cut her
video last week of her chopping up sweet
potatoes while she talked about how the
world was a terrible place in her
climate-controlled apartment in the
heart of the Navy Yard in Washington DC
she's very difficult life here in the
first world now she's she's claiming
well I'm not a hypocrite you know
everybody has to use this stuff it's not
hypocrisy if everybody is using this
stuff that is not enough for the former
head of Greenpeace the co-founder of
Greenpeace
he slammed her he has a PhD in ecology
is name is Patrick Moore
he said he
he fired back the world as it is has the
option of taking the subway rather than
taxi the option of Amtrak rather than
plane the option of opening windows
rather than AC here's just a
garden-variety hypocrite like the others
and you have zero expertise at any of
the things you pretend to know he's
blasted her before he called her after
she suggested that that she was the boss
he said pompous little twit you don't
have a plan to grow food for 8 billion
people without fossil fuels or get the
food into the cities horses if fossil
fuels were banned every tree in the
world would be cut down for fuel for
cooking and heating you would bring
about mass death that founder of
Greenpeace owning a OSE with facts and
logic that is not stopping members of
the media from coming forth to defend
her and the rest of the fresh faces
elizabeth bruenig who's the socialist
stylist over at The Washington Post I
mean she legitimately defends socialism
she defended Ilhan Omar's anti-semitism
this week she said it's not actual
anti-semitism to accuse people of dual
loyalty but then she wrote a full piece
in The Washington Post in which she
suggests that AOC is not in fact a
hypocrite and we should ignore people
who call socialists hypocrites now
here's the truth socialism always ends
with the two-track process there are the
people who run the government who live
lives of extraordinary wealth and
privilege it was always good to be a
member of the government in the USSR way
better than being a member of the
proletariat in Venezuela if you are a
member of the Chavez family with the
majority great place to be if you're
anyone else you're eating dogs socialism
tends to end up with a two-track program
but Elizabeth brooding says we should
ignore the fact that AOC is willing to
take care of all these advantages
because you know she's fighting to
change the world this is always the way
that folks tend to get off the hook you
know it's fascinating when you think of
government as God and when you think
that you are God because you are a
member of government the rules don't
apply to you you're like God you exist
outside space and time and the rules can
simply be changed at whim when you're
not a member of government then personal
responsibility falls on you to do the
things that you are talking about so
when I talk about building the social
fabric and giving charity I need to
actually work on building the social
fabric and giving charity I can't just
say listen I'm fighting for those things
we don't actually have to do those
things the I generally am not a fan of
the hypocrisy claim the hypocrisy claim
is very often used to tear down the
standard itself so what I mean is
you will see somebody who says adultery
is bad and then they go and they commit
adultery and people say well that
person's a hypocrite hypocrisy is not
failing to live up to your own standards
hypocrisy is saying that the standards
should not apply to me it should apply
to everyone else well that's what a OSI
is doing she's saying that I'm living in
the world as it is right so are the rest
of us AOC so are the rest of us and yet
you're calling on all of us to radically
change how we live our lives and you're
not gonna worry about it you're not
doing it right that's hypocrisy
suggesting there's one set of rules for
you and one set of rules for the
commoners that is hypocrisy failing to
live up to your own expectations is not
so FeO see it said listen I'm trying I'm
doing my best
I don't always live up to the standard
but that's something we can all work on
that would be a good defense not I live
in the world so do all of us we're all
living here together
but Elizabeth brutix says we should just
ignore all of this she says shortly
after AOC won a congressional primary
pictures of her childhood home began
appearing on social media the grainy
image of the small blue cottage was
evidently swiped from Google Streetview
and uploaded to Twitter by conservative
television host John Cardillo the tidy
little home card Zillow tweeted was in
fact the Yorktown Heights very nice area
home of AOC a far cry from the Bronx
hood upbringing she's selling her Dilla
was wrong Ocasio was born in the Bronx
though her family moved to Yorktown
Heights years later in an effort to
place her in better public schools well
then he wasn't wrong that's where she
lived growing up my wife was born in
Haifa she didn't live in a fight for her
entire upbringing like that's silly
and then AOC says as more left flank
challengers face off with center-left
incumbents and more democratic
socialists begin looking toward public
office beware
you will all be called champagne
socialists or yacht communists the
richer and more radical counterparts of
limousine liberals it doesn't matter how
comparatively humble your background is
or how relatively modest your means in
the context of the political class at
large it'll always be news if Bernie
Sanders wears a $700 coat or buys a
house by a lake because his political
position on inequality is so obviously
moral that the only way to impeach it is
to make him seem dishonest about it no
it is not obviously moral it is
obviously immoral which is why he
doesn't live up to his own morality his
own standard is bullcrap everybody knows
it's bullcrap
he knows it's bullcrap that's why we
point out that he lives on a house by
the lake not to say that owning a house
by a lake is inherently bad but to say
that there's nothing wrong with owning a
house by the lake and this is out
there suggesting that there's something
inherently
moral about owning a house by the lake
at the same time he owns one that's the
point
a protic says the same goes and will
continue to go for every other candidate
who attempts to advance material
equality this stance is hard to supply a
persuasive democratic alternative to so
critics instead claim that as standard
bearers don't really mean it no we claim
that the standard itself is nonsense and
no one lives up to it specifically
because it's nonsense that's the point
AOC lives in the world as it is she
expects everyone else not to live in the
world as it is it is not just that she
is called for change and innovation and
technology we're all doing that right
now everyone right left and center the
difference is that she says that it is
immoral for there to be billionaires she
says that it is immoral to live certain
lifestyles so does Sanders you can't
live those lifestyles and then at the
same time claiming is immoral to live
those lifestyles in the now that is
called a double standard
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like there is a movie out on
Amazon now called beautiful boy it's
based on a memoir from a New Yorker
writer whose son became addicted to
crystal meth the movie is what's good
about the movies that is really well
acted that's that's the part of the
movie that's really great I won't say
that it's deeply emotionally affecting
but it is really well acted Timothy
Chalmette is a terrific actor he plays
the the meth-addicted son and you do
learn a fair bit about meth addiction
how virulent it is how terrible it is
here is a little bit of the preview so
how you doing I'm great
just doing what needs to be done what
does that mean I'm sorry dad why don't
we just have lunch and talk we can do
that right please you think that you
have this under control I understand why
I do things it doesn't make me any
different you're just embarrassed
because I was like you know I was like
this amazing thing like your special
creation or something and you know like
Who I am now yeah who are you Nick this
is me dad here this is who I am this is
not you this is not you Nick what are
you doing Oh Joe
gotta be controlling everything all the
time let me let me book you at a hotel
for a couple of nights I want it to go
like this
[Music]
my son so the movie is is quite good one
of the things that it does show you and
it is it is true is that Timothy Shalom
it's performance so much of it is that
when you are dealing with with folks who
are addicted or who have a mental
problem so many so much of it is an
attempt to turn the the question back on
you you see in that specific scene it's
a very good scene
one of the things that you see in that
scene is is Timothy Shalom it's
character trying to blame the dad for
his own problems and this is if you want
to be successful in life honestly if I'm
basically and I forget about addiction
for a second you want to be successful
in life generally the most important
thing is to take personal responsibility
for your actions if you actually want to
be successful in life blaming your
parents blaming your upbringing blaming
your environment none of that avails
because reality is still reality and
good decision-making is going to be
rewarded in a far more coherent way than
bad decision-making trying to blame the
world trying to blame other people
doesn't avail you one bit and I
understand that our modern American
policy is based on the blame game it's
based on this idea that every problem
you experience in your life is due to
some unseen impersonal forces that are
out there again there's some people who
are legitimately victimized by
individual people but if we actually
want a country of success we need a
country of successful people being a
successful person means taking
responsibility for your own actions and
that's true that's is true for people
who are not addicts as it is true for
people who happen to be addicts okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
so I'm old enough to remember when it
was considered very very bad not to
respect the results of an election
Hillary Clinton has been doing that ever
since she lost I was told that if Donald
Trump lost in 2016 he was not going to
respect the results of the election I'm
being told by people like Michael Cohen
that if President Trump doesn't win in
2020 there will be a civil war because
Trump will refused to leave office
Hillary Clinton is still doing this
stick she's still doing this stick but
she's doing it about stacey abrams so
stacey abrams lost her gubernatorial
race in georgia she lost it fair and
square she did not lose and she lost my
something like 50,000 votes that's not
stopping hillary clinton from going down
to Selma and suggesting that stacey
abrams really did win and also Hillary
got back into her southern accent it's
always fun to watch Hillary's modulating
accents she's like the the
extraordinarily crappy Daniel day-lewis
of political accents we're looking
toward
new presidential election thank goodness
but it's not going to make a difference
if we don't bring the lawsuits and win
them right if we don't register
everybody the way Stacey Abrams has been
doing since 2014 I mean just think about
it between 2012 the prior presidential
election where we still had the Voting
Rights Act and 2016 when my name was on
the ballot there were fewer voters
registered in Georgia than there had
been those prior four years okay she's a
delight I mean I do love her dropping
the southern accent by the way it got
even stronger I mean here's a clip of
her talking again in Selma I mean she
really is dropping those G's she's just
leaving those G's out there on the
street for anyone to trip over it's
really unsafe and strong you have been a
wonderful host thank you so much it is a
great honor to be back among you
especially at this moment that is
fraught with peril for our country and
Reverend green when those bones get up
and when that spirit is breathed into
them and they start climbing out of that
Valley the first place they go is to
register to vote okay men she and
kirsten gillibrand cut from the exact
same Club I'd like to see an acting off
between Kirsten Gillibrand and Hillary
Clinton is it I sometimes wonder if
Hillary Clinton and Kirsten Gillibrand
are actually the same person just
separated by 20 years I don't know at
this point okay in any case we'll be
back here for two hours
later today so make sure you subscribe
and then you can stop by for the updates
and all sorts of fun you can check in
with us during the breaks and I'll
answer your questions it should be a
blast so go check us out over at daily
where I come or we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19